hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast evaporation versus my
optimization the three deciding factors
I am the shuttle action of laberd's and
I will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab routes and
sponsored by lab console or more
information on our sponsor places it's
WWF conquer calm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send I'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'd be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I'd like to now introduce
our presenters Meghan Zimmerman the
product manager at Lancome corporation
to learn more about our speakers please
visit the speaker tab at the top of the
presentation window Meghan you may not
begin your presentation
Thank You Michelle and thank you to
everyone for joining today we'll be
talking about what you need to know
before deciding whether evaporation or
lyophilization is the right method for
your sample
we'll start with a brief introduction
for viewing some common terms space
changes and the three factors you need
to consider to determine which method is
right for your work then we'll review
the differences between concentrators
evaporators and breeze dryers at this
point you should have a good idea of
what process is right for you so we'll
end things by discussing how to select
equipment based on your samples and mean
first let's begin by reviewing some
common terms you'll hear when talking
about freeze drying and evaporation
lyophilization which is another word for
freeze drying is the process of removing
moisture from a frozen product using
vacuum derived from the Greek word
solvent loving my awful ice samples are
easily rehydrated making it a great
process for sample preparation and
long-term storage because you can easily
resuspend your samples sublimation is
another word you'll hear when talking
about freeze drying this is the process
and freeze drying in which solvents
passed directly from the solid phase to
the gas phase
giving freeze-dried samples such great
preservation properties because you are
bypassing the liquid phase the rate at
which sublimation occurs is dependent on
temperature and pressure evaporation is
the process in which solvents pass from
a liquid to a vapor state due to an
increase in temperature and pressure
evaporation is a relatively quick
process taking minutes to hours to
complete making this a great option for
people looking for sample prep equipment
this graph shows what's happening to
your sample when you freeze dry or
evaporates for sublimation within freeze
drying to occur you need to have a cold
enough temperature and a deep enough
document for your sample to go from a
solid to a gas if either of these things
does not occur the sample will actually
evaporate and not get the preservation
properties that you would get the
sublimation
this makes pressure and temperature
critical components of freeze drains
while freeze-drying it is important to
cool the material below its triple point
which is shown on the graph the triple
point is the highest temperature at
which the solid and liquid phases of the
material can coexist being below this
point ensures that sublimation rather
than evaporation will occur when trying
to decide which evaporation or freeze
drying method you should use for your
work there are three important factors
you should always consider the first
factor is a pretty basic question what
type of samples are you working with are
you working with solvents or acids that
can be tough on stainless steel acrylic
or rubber components or are you working
with aqueous samples maybe you're
working with alcohol samples that have a
very low freezing point factoring in
your sample solvents or alcohol content
is very important when deciding what
type of equipment you should use to
complete your work it is also important
for you to know if your sample is heat
sensitive or volatile before deciding
which method is right for you
the second factor you need to consider
is your sample volume this is important
for individual sample volume as well as
total run volumes most evaporation
equipment can handle individual sample
volumes from one milliliter to several
hundred milliliters freeze dryers on the
other hand can handle volumes up to
several liters allowing for greater
sample through pets
finally the third factor you should
consider is what is your sample being
used for for many people only looking to
complete a step four sample preparation
evaporation equipment will be enough for
those who are working with samples meant
for long-term storage freeze drying
equipment will be the way to go
now let's talk a little about what makes
these methods and equipment different
from each other first step we'll discuss
discuss the center of AB concentrators
these concentrators are meant for slower
evaporation of smaller sample sizes as
the samples been in a centrifugal motion
at a fixed speed not to be confused with
centrifuges these concentrators operate
at 1725 rpm meaning no separation of the
sample from the supernat
this process
the center bap also operates on a vacuum
delay allowing the rotor to reach
maximum speed for the vacuum turns on
protecting your samples the method of
evaporation the center of abuses is
evaporative cooling since the heat
source does not come into direct contact
with the sample this makes a
concentrator a great choice for those of
you who are working with heat sensitive
samples the heat timer also runs
independently from the run timer so you
can limit the amount of heat your sample
is exposed to for those of you who are
working with solvents the center vApp is
capable of solvent recovery when paired
with the cold traps
the cold traps are offered at 3
temperatures - 50 degrees Celsius - 85
degrees Celsius and - 105 degrees
Celsius and your selection should be
made depending on your solvents freezing
points concentrators are suitable for
most sample types including aqueous
samples solvents and alcohols as well as
low concentrations of acids the center
DAP can accommodate sample volumes of
half a milliliter up to 50 milliliters
depending on the rotor you select
several suits tube sizes are able to be
used as well as micro L and deep well
plates but Congo offers six types of
Center vat concentrators meeting
everyone's needs the refrigerated center
of AB concentrator is a great option for
those of you working with small volumes
of DNA RNA or proteomics work but the
ability to heat the chamber up to a
hundred degrees Celsius but also cool it
to minus four degrees Celsius
this is a great choice for people
working with very heat sensitive samples
this model also comes with a chamber
pre-cooling option as well as being
available in an acid-resistant model the
acid resistance Center valve uses robust
materials to create a corrosion
resistant concentrator materials include
PTFE coated chamber hastelloy shaft
ceramic ball bearings a glass lid and
PTFE coated rotors all of these
components of the concentrator resist
exposure to corrosion from low to
moderate concentrations of acids like
TFA
HCl acetic acid and ammonium hydroxide
the DNA center of apps is a great
all-in-one solution for those working
with small volumes of DNA samples it
comes complete with a micro centrifuge
tube rotor a built in diaphragm pump and
two glass traps these traps help protect
any solvents from reaching the vacuum
and potentially causing damage they also
help to keep the evaporated solvent from
being exhausted back out into the room
the other three models in our Center
about concentrator lineups are also
all-in-one models that accommodate a
variety of uses and needs the center
back completes the concentrator cold
trap and diaphragm come fall and a
single bench top packaged the micro IR
is ideal for small sample throughput of
most sample types the materials used are
designed to help provide corrosion
resistance against low concentrations of
some harsh solvents it comes with the
PTFE coated chamber and sample River a
built in PTFE coated diaphragm pumps an
infrared admitting glass lid and a
vacuum gauge the micro IR is also small
enough to fit in nearly any lab space
and weighing only 20 pounds is light
enough to be carried from lab to lab
for anyone limited on my bench space the
center Bob mobile concentrator would be
a great choice it comes with all of the
same design features as our bench top
concentrators it has been designed to
house all necessary components in a
mobile console that you would need for
successful concentration of samples
including a built in cold trap for
solvent recovery
next let's talk about it operators rapid
farid operators are meant to provide
fast evaporation of larger samples
through a vortex motion unlike the
centrifugal motion of the concentrators
this vortex motion creates a constant
wash down of the sample tubes while
increasing surface area helping to speed
the rate of evaporation the wash down of
the tubes also allows for better
recovery rates the rapid rapid operators
use dry heat that comes into direct
contact with the sample compared to the
heated chamber of the concentrator
depending on the model selected the
rapid bath uses either nitrogen blowdown
or backing its operation
however if solvent recovery is a must
for your work then you need to go with
the vacuum evaporation models
if solvent recovery isn't a factor for
you then you could go with vacuum or
nitrogen blowdown evaporation with
vacuum evaporation the pressure in the
vial is reduced below the vapor pressure
of the liquid this allows the sample to
evaporate at a lower temperature than
normal using nitrogen the sample is
evaporated by reducing the partial
pressure over the sample tube allowing
the samples to take more heat inputs
this also tends to be a gentler way to
evaporate samples
not ideal for heat sensitive samples the
rapid vapid operators are able to be
used for all other sample types
concluding volatile samples and strong
concentrations of acids on nearly all
models the rapid copy vaporators are
made with robust materials to handle
corrosion including a PTFE coated
aluminum chamber and sample block as
well as the glass lens the evaporator
can also handle handle larger sample
volumes compared to the concentrator
ranging from one milliliter up to 450
milliliters and includes audible alarm
signals to indicate the desired end
point of the sample has been achieved
Levchenko offers four types of rapid
rapid operators one vacuum system and
three nitrogen blowdown systems the
rapid feb document operator paired with
a cold trap is especially meant for
those of you who need solvent recovery
during your runs however it is also a
great choice for volatile samples for
volatile samples run the risk of bumping
under a deep vacuum the rapid Val vacuum
evaporator comes with full vacuum
control allowing you to precisely set
the vacuum level and then of my sample
loss while still speeding evaporation
the glass lid also comes with the heater
to prevent condensation on the lid to
help prevent cross-contamination between
samples the sample volume range for this
evaporator is 4.5 milliliters up to 450
milliliters to obtain even greater
solvent recovery rates with the vacuum
evaporator consider pairing vacuum
evaporation and cold traps at the rapid
stop trapping valves this valve is
placed between the evaporator and cold
traps
slowing down the solvent transition from
the evaporator allowing the cold trap to
work more effectively this trapping
valve is only for use with the rapid
that vacuum evaporator and it's not able
to be used with the nitrogen blowdown
system
rapid vertex is a nitrogen blowdown
evaporator however instead of the
samples moving in a vortex motion they
are kept in a fixed angled position
inside a sample block the angle gives
the samples a greater surface area and
optimized recovery this design is
similar to water bath evaporators in the
way that heat and nitrogen are delivered
to the samples however the dry block
heater requires less maintenance no rust
and no condensation buildup on the lid
to cause cross-contamination between
samples sample throughput of the vertex
is also a little different from our
other rapid die evaporators depending on
the block selected the vertex has a
throughput of up to 50 samples with
volumes ranging from one milliliter up
to 60 milliliters if you're looking for
temperature monitoring the vertex
includes a temperature sensor so you can
monitor the block or sample temperature
throughout your run for more volatile
samples the vertex also includes a built
in nitrogen pressure regulator to
control the pressure that is delivered
to the samples if you aren't running a
full block of samples the vertex is also
designed to help reduce the use of
nitrogen with a control valve but
delivers nitrogen only two rows four
samples have been place
so wrap it up vertex evaporator is ideal
for preparation of samples in a variety
of applications including drug discovery
environmental testing and forensic
evidence processing
offered us a more efficient automatic
alternative to rotary evaporators the
rapid fab n 2 and n 248 offer some
unique features as a nitrogen blowdown
evaporator similar to the vertex
nitrogen reduces the partial presser
pressure directly over the liquid and
the samples come into direct contact
with heat
however the samples also move in a
vortex motion this motion is
microprocessor controlled to help
increase the surface area of the sample
and speed the rate of adoption usage is
also conserved by being able to deliver
the nitrogen in clusters when full
sample loads are not required
these evaporators are ideal for those
who aren't looking to take their samples
to complete drain us with the unique
cool zone that insulates samples and
stem glassware below the heated blocks
it allows samples adequate time to be
removed before reaching dryness the
maximum individual sample volume for
these evaporators is up to 450
milliliters finally let's talk about
freeze dryers different from
concentrators and evaporators freeze
dryers require a completely frozen
sample prior to beginning sublimation
this is the only way to achieve the
desired preservation properties this
type of method can provide to drive the
moisture out of samples free strayer's
use deep vacuum and either evaporative
cooling sea of death via flask freeze
drying or direct heat through heated
product shelves as the moisture is
pulled out of your samples the vapor is
drawn down towards the collector coils
of your freeze dryer where it collects
this ice throughout the course of the
run freeze own freeze dryers can be used
for nearly all sample types as long as
the correct equipment is selected if you
are working with low to moderate acid
concentrations PTFE coating is required
in order to protect your freeze dryer
from corrosion alcohols can also be used
with freeze dryers but due to the low
freezing point we recommend only using a
concentration of 10% or less
otherwise you run the risk of the vapor
not being trapped by the collector coils
freeze own freeze dryers are available
in three collector temperatures and for
most sample types we recommend a
collector temperature of minus 50
degrees Celsius for aqueous samples
minus 84 degrees Celsius for most
solvents and minus 105 degrees Celsius
for alcohols knowing your sample
freezing point will help you determine
which collector temperature you need
freeze dryers can be used as a sample
prep step if you are planning to quickly
reconstitute your sample that would not
be as quick as evaporation however if
you are planning if you are working
large volumes of heat sensitive samples
freeze drying would be the best option
for your work because freeze drying is
best for long-term storage of samples it
makes this the ideal method for things
like pharmaceuticals research and
development or food storage preparation
the ice holding capacity of freeze
dryers also allows for much greater
throughput of samples compared to
evaporators or concentrators with freeze
own freeze dryers holding a minimum of
2.5 litres of ice and can hold a maximum
of 18 litres of ice before needing to be
defrosted there are also a number of
drying accessories available so your
work can be completed in a number of
ways including the ability to stopper
samples under vacuum
Freezone breeze dryers come in standard
bench top and console for models but
Lubchenco also offers a unique
all-in-one model for those of you who
are working with relatively smaller
sample volumes but also need to stop for
your samples under a vacuum for
long-term storage the free zone triad
acts as a freezer to pre freeze your
samples on the shelf
prior to starting your run you can also
freeze dry your samples in a multiple in
multiple ways without purchasing
additional drying accessories whether
it's through flasks freeze drying and
via the ports on the side of the machine
or through bulk or vial freeze drying on
the shelves all of these features are
wrapped up into one compact bench top
freeze dryer that has an ice holding
capacity of 2.5 liters
with its minus 85 degrees Celsius
collector temperature it can handle most
sample types and it's a versatile option
for many types of research if time is
limited for sample throughput the end
zone endpoint detection system is a
critical component for any flask for
e-string it alerts you to when endpoint
has been achieved based on the level of
dryness you set prior to the start of
the run it is important to know with
certainty that samples are finished
before the lay operation run sentence if
samples are removed prematurely
they will not be viable for the long
term storage you may be expecting
now that we have reviewed the
differences between concentrators
evaporators and free traders let's talk
briefly about how to select the
equipment you need based on the process
you've chosen when selecting a freeze
dryer there are four main components to
consider the first is determining what
collector temperature you require in
order to trap the vapor coming off your
samples the collector temperature should
be 15 to 20 degrees Celsius colder than
the freezing point of your sample the
second component is determining what
collector size and type you need for any
run your collector size should be two
times larger than the total run volume
you plan to put on the freeze dryer so
if you have a total of two litres of
sample to run you would select a freeze
dryer with a nice holding capacity of 4
litres or larger you also need to
consider what solvents you may be using
with your samples if you are working
with anything that may be corrosive to
stainless steel you will want to get a
PTFE coated collector chamber and coils
the third component is selecting what
drying accessory you'll need are you
planning to freeze dry your samples in
flasks or do you need to stop for your
samples under vacuums whatever drawing
accessories selects it should meet the
needs of your process whether it is for
sample preparation or long-term storage
finally you'll need to select a vacuum
pump that meets the needs of your sample
types and throughputs freeze-drying
requires a vacuum pump that can reach
100 microns and a displacement of 98
liters per minute however you also want
to take into consideration what types of
samples you'll be freeze-drying if you
are working with acids or any solvents
that can cause corrosion you would want
to select a vacuum hums that is chemical
resistance such as a hybrid combination
of a rotary vane and diaphragm pump or
an oil-free tunned such as the scroll
thumb if you are only working with
aqueous samples the rotary vane oil pump
will be adequate for your needs
to select a concentrator or evaporator
there are three main components to
consider the first would be a general
review of your sample information what
is your individual sample volume and
tube size that you plan to use is your
sample heat sensitive how many samples
do you need to complete per run
what solvents are being used all of
these questions are critical to
determining which equipment would be
right for you another important
consideration to take into account is
whether or not solvent recovery is
required if yes then you narrow your
possible choices down to document
operation or concentration in order to
be able to use a cold trap
the final point to consider is what
available resources you have maybe you
already have a vacuum comes available
for you and you just need to ensure
chemical compatibility and overall
displacement of the pumps if you are
looking to use a nitrogen evaporation
system you need to ensure your
facilities either have an in-house
supply line where you are able to
acquire a nitrogen generator either of
these options are required to use this
type of equipment as the nitrogen tank
would not be enough to supply an entire
run
before we end today I want to identify
some additional resources for you as you
work to make a decision about what
equipment is best for your samples and
overall process on the lab Congo website
we have a number of articles that could
be of help to you discussing the
differences between evaporation and
lyophilization
as well as how to process and
challenging samples we also offer
product configurators for our freeze
dryers and evaporators these
configurators will walk you through
similar concepts and questions that were
discussed here helping you to select
equipment that will work for your
samples for any additional questions
please feel free to reach out for a
contact submission of one live chat or
by calling lab concur directly and
asking to speak with an application
specialist
Thank You Megan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
will answer many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started okay our
first question is what is the best
evaporation option if my samples are
heat sensitive
that's a really great question and you
know like we talked about in the webinar
it really depends on a couple of
different things the first being what's
the overall purpose of your samples are
they just part of a sample prep step in
the overall process or are you working
with something that needs to be stored
long term so if it's the former and
you're just doing a step in your process
the DNA center of app or any of our
Center Bop line really would be the best
option for you and your heat-sensitive
sample if you're working with smaller
volumes and if you're working with
larger volumes or have the need for
long-term storage using a freeze dryer
would be your best option for your
heat-sensitive samples
great thank you all right your next
question how is heat delivered to the
samples in the vertex evaporator
so on the vertex the heat is actually
coming from the bottom of where your
aluminum block is place and now even
though it's not also heating from the
sides of that block the block was
designed and made with aluminum which
helps ensure greater temperature
uniformity throughout the block so that
single heat source and is adequate for
heating your samples throughout the
entire aluminum block
great thank you okay next question how
do you recommend exhausting solvent out
of a lab if I am using nitrogen
evaporation
that's a really great question so with
our nitrogen evaporators you aren't able
to use a cold trap to trap your solvent
and that has to do with the overall
freezing point of nitrogen being so low
so what we recommend is said is a couple
of things you can place your nitrogen
evaporator and your vacuum comes
directly into a fume hood and vent out
that way or only place your vacuum pump
in the fume head and you can also if you
aren't close to a fume hood use vacuum
tubing and connect that to the outlet of
your exhaust on your vacuum pump and I'm
sorry not vacuum Kemp to the nitrogen
evaporator and and direct that to your
fume hood - it's locked out
great Thank You Megan it looks like all
the questions we have at the moment I do
want to remind the audience that you can
submit questions during the on-demand
period and those that are submitted
during that period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
I'd like to thank Megan we'd also like
to take levers and our sponsors I'll go
for underwriting today's educational
webcast Babur's will alert you via email
when it's available to replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
suffice